record-setting heat has for years marked
the beginning of summers in europe
this year high temperatures turned
italy's alpine region long known for
mountains glaciers and outdoor sports
into a death trap
on sunday hikers and climbers were
caught in an avalanche on the marmalade
mountain one of italy's highest peaks
more than a dozen people were killed or
seriously injured from falling ice and
snow
the marmalade are practically the peak
had collapsed and the pig is nothing but
a huge piece of ice that broke off and
it ran over everyone who was on the
glacier the various mountain climbers
who were going up or down when we
arrived there we found ourselves in
front of a horrible scene because there
were blocks of ice and enormous rocks
everywhere
rescuers estimate more than a dozen
people are missing
but the search was suspended
high temperatures making the risk of
another avalanche too high scientists
have for decades been warning about the
marmalade glacier shrinking
the changing climate causing glacial
melt on a global scale
and accelerating the dangers it poses
ravi al-jazeera